Welcome, Mr. Kataya.
Which girl would you like?
I'd like the most popular girl.
Sure, that's Mikoto.
Hi, thanks for choosing me. I'm Mikoto.
What kind of place is this?
Is this really for fortune telling?
INVISIBLE
Okay, go ahead, spit out your problems.
I'm planning to commit suicide tomorrow.
This is heavy.
I've lost very important documents.
It'll be a ten-million-dollar damage
to the company.
Too heavy.
My life is like shit.
I don't have any friends
let alone a girlfriend.
I work 20 hours a day, and as a result,
ten million dollars in debt?
Even with my lifetime income,
I can't repay that. What was my life?
He's so stressed out. Now I feel bad
that I thought this place was pervy.
-This is a fortune teller house.
-I see.
The documents are in your house.
It can't be.
I've searched throughout the house.
There's a bookshelf with collectable
bottle caps of coke lined up on top of it.
-How do you know that?
-Very nostalgic.
You'll find them under the bookshelf.
Right, I didn't search there.
I'll go find that out.
-Yeah, go check it out.
-She is amazing.
I can't search for something
I've never seen. I kinda envy her.
Okay, next!
My puppy has been missing for three days.
Okay. Do you know a house with
liquor bottles lined up by the window?
They're taking care of him.
-Let me ask you straight!
-So weird.
Will I get married someday?
Your future wife is in Masvingo,
located in the southeast of Zimbabwe.
-Mikoto, please have a break.
-Thanks!
I have many new clients today.
But I'm in great condition and confident,
so I can do more.
Oh man! I'll gain more popularity!
Don't say "Oh man." Good grief,
this is more serious than I thought.
Her fortune telling is too precise.